just hours after gunmen rampage through
their newsroom the dedicated staff at
the Capitol Gazette company in Annapolis
published their regular morning paper
today five of their colleagues were
killed in the attack the victims range
in age from 34 to 65 years old they
include four journalists and a sales
assistant for the newspaper CBS News has
new information on why the suspected
shooter may have carried out the attack
armed with smoke and flash grenade and a
shotgun police say the suspect who we've
identified as 38 year old Jarrod Ramos
threatened the Capitol Gazette a few
hours before the shooting he is charged
with five counts of first degree murder
nore O'Donnell is outside the newspapers
offices in Annapolis nor a good morning
hey good morning to all of you let me
just tell you there's some new
information this morning the suspect
will be in court this morning the police
chief here telling CBS this morning they
do believe that he acted alone
the chief also saying that authorities
are still processing this crime scene
behind me but they believe they will be
finished this morning and of course many
are still grieving the five victims
after what is one of the deadliest
attacks on journalists in US history
now even though five of the Capitol
Gazette staff were killed in this
morning several of the roughly 30 strong
editorial staff were seen working in a
nearby garage after the attack they were
covering this story while the fate of
their friends and colleagues were still
unknown we saw one of the editors of the
paper tweeted last night yes we're
putting out a damn paper tomorrow and so
guys here it is this is the front page
of the Capitol Gazette this is actually
one of the oldest newspapers in the
country and so with a small staff left
they put together this newspaper and
they're saying that this Capitol team
will be back to work today
even as they grieve for the five lives
lost when the shooter stormed in
shots have been fired and these 10 shots
hurt just before 3 p.m. the gunman
entered building eight eight eight
carrying smoke bombs flash grenades a
shotgun and headed straight for the
Gazette newsroom this person was
prepared today to come in this person
was prepared to shoot people his intent
was to cause harm employees hid under
their desks while the shooters bullets
pierced the glass front door some said
they could hear screams as their friends
fell around them door the Capitol
because that had been blown to pieces it
was in shattered pieces all on the
carpet and this guy was moving across
the entrance of the Capitol Gazette
office pointing the gun deeper into the
office like he was targeting people all
five victims were gunned down on the
building's first floor a Gazette
reporter Phil Davis described the
frightening scene as a war zone and said
there is nothing more terrifying than
hearing multiple people get shot while
you're under your desk and then hear the
gunman reload police arrived to the
office in about 60 seconds to confront
the shooter in that time they evacuated
a hundred and seventy people from the
building who exited with their hands
raised high in the air authorities
quickly surrounded the shooter and
arrested him without exchanging gunfire
law enforcement sources tell CBS News
the shooter was hiding under a desk and
it damaged his finger tips to make it
harder for police to identify him with
fingerprints but federal authorities
later used facial recognition technology
to determine just who he was police then
searched his home for any clues a lot of
moving parts our primary job right now
is to make sure that we prosecute enough
evidence to make sure that we can
prosecute this case
and I should tell you guys um this is
also part of the the paper this morning
this is the opinion page look at this
this actually got me really choked up
this morning it says today we are
speechless this page is intentionally
left blank today to commemorate the
victims of Thursday's shooting in our
office